hi I'm cat and I'm really excited to
introduce you to three YC alumni
founders and and this is actually going
to dovetail really nicely with what
Christy and Aileen were just talking
about because we're going to be talking
a little bit about fundraising because
we all know that that's a big challenge
and then hopefully we can get to a
couple questions beyond that but these
three women are running companies that
you know cover a wide range of
categories we have you know something
from the sciences marketplace feminine
hygiene we also have companies here at
different stages so Erika from flex just
went through YC in the summer last
summer and raised a seed Elizabeth went
through in what was it someone 2012
summer 2011 and she just announced her
series series today so congratulation
makes it huge news and Vanessa with gold
belly went through YC in winter 2013 and
raised a series a Brooke Lite series a
last year so we have a wide range of
categories we have a wide range of you
know kind of stages so I'm really
excited and for you all to kind of tell
your story so can you each introduce
yourselves talk a little bit about what
your company does and where you're at
today great so I'm Elizabeth Lyons I'm
the founder and CEO of science exchange
science exchange is a marketplace for
outsourced research and development we
work with some of the world's largest
pharmaceutical companies as well as
agriscience cosmetics aerospace and food
science companies to help them manage
their outsourced research and
development we have just made so
seriousiy we have been in operation for
six years and through that process have
built the company now to a global stage
so it's very exciting it's awesome
all right Vanessa yeah
my name is Vanessa papariga
and I am the co-founder and chief
creative officer of gold belly as Kat
said we did winner 2013 we are a
marketplace where you can discover the
greatest most iconic regional foods from
everywhere in the country shipped to
your door through us you can experience
places like Momofuku Milk Bar and
Magnolia Bakery in New York felt like
barbecue in Texas and we ship it to you
no matter where you're located
we recently raised ten million dollars
series a and yeah we're we're doing
pretty well right now Erica I'm Erica
I'm the co-founder of the Flex company
like Kat said we went through YC
actually twice last year and we closed
the four million dollar seed round in
September our product is called flex
it's a new menstrual product that
replaces tampons pads and menstrual cups
you can wear it for 12 hours it's
disposable you can have mass free period
sex while wearing it and we started
shipping to customers in October and
we're currently on a multi-million
dollar run right awesome I wanted to do
one really quick survey in the audience
how many of you braced money okay okay
how many of you raised a seed seer today
okay series B okay okay so now we know
where we're at okay so on a scale from
one to ten where one is easy peasy
and ten it's the hardest thing you've
ever had to do with founders how hard
you think say raising your theory your
seed was on that scale for us it was
probably a four okay not the hardest
there's a point on that I feel like it
was more like a nine raising a seed
because it's fund raising it's not
something that you want to do you didn't
start a company to fundraise
I would give it like a 9 I think the
first check is the hardest check you're
ever going to close and that was for
sure a really solid 9 and everything
beyond that was kind of a 4-2 how far
along were your products when you first
raised money well so we manufacture a
type 2 medical device that's regulated
by the FDA so we weren't very far at all
because as you can imagine that costs a
lot of money so we were really an idea
in a design and an early prototype and a
founding team we had customers and we
were demonstrating growth and you know
we were generating some good revenue so
we were super early so we alphas money
in was Y Combinator actually and we had
nothing we didn't have even a website
and then after Y Combinator we'd build a
website and don't initial customers and
had some revenue and at that stage was
really raised our angel round so you
mentioned that getting that first check
was really hard
how many investors you have to talk to
you or or what was that experience like
before you closed
Erica talked to countless investors for
us fundraising is a lot like hiring like
you really want to align yourself with
people that you want to continue working
with and that you genuinely like I think
Eileen said don't work with [ __ ]
right and so it was important to find
people in the beginning who not only
believed in us but really believed in
the product and believed in the mission
that the product would achieve so how
did you practice for those first
investor meetings what did practice look
like I think for us we got a lot of
practice during YC we were pitching to
our peers we pitched to PG he gave us
some amazing tips on you know some
things that we should really put out
front and center so it was mostly
talking to people who are going through
similar you know fundraising instances
that we really learned how to do it so
you tried to talk to pitchers many other
founders you could even feedback yeah we
wanted to
focus on things that people were
reacting to and they were like nodding
to you wanted them to respond with a
question yes not just have a glaze yeah
is it was not a good thing what we were
saying and what did that your kind of
practice process look like so part of
the challenge here and for many of you
is is for selling this company to people
often you know a lot of investors are
white men who aren't necessarily your
users right most investors aren't
scientists or you know they're not women
who have periods so how did you own that
messaging like how did you get to the
right you know kind of message that
story to tell investors yeah I think the
storytelling is really important
particularly in the early phases and for
us I'm not sure that we were very good
at it at the beginning so definitely for
us it was a journey evolution of trying
to understand what would resonate with
investors as an audience and what we
ultimately came down to was really
describing the business so instead of
being very focused on what's most
exciting to me which is enabling
breakthrough research that was not you
know people got excited about it but it
wasn't to them something that they
really wanted to invest money in and
what really resonated with people was
when they understood the market size and
they understood that this was a new
market that was wide open where no
software existed and that there was a
huge transactional cost that science
exchange would eliminate that they could
really see that the economic benefit of
science exchange was so compelling that
this would be something that could
create a truly billion-dollar business
and so that's where we were able to
really start to raise significant
financing did it take you a few tries so
did you pitch to a few investors who you
know you were pitching your and your
other scientists with someone you know
from your background the things that
excite you as you said are the things
that excite investors did you sort of
have a couple people to practice on like
or did you make a few mistakes before
you got the right message made a lots of
mistakes for sure yeah I think for us we
tried to tell some interesting stories
about use cases that had happened on
science exchange like one of our
favorite ones was Nasir use science
exchange
to develop the blackest material ever
measured and we were like that is so
cool people should really care about
this and it's a great story but it's not
a great investor story and so not
clearly describing why that could create
a valuable business opportunity it was
definitely a mistake and we sort of
evolved from there and actually
developed much more of an economic based
pitch which resonated much much more
strongly and Erica you're gonna have to
tell us how you picked up a Syrian
product how did you get comfortable
doing not even I don't know that I own
control here it was just something that
we really believed in and if we didn't
talk about it with everyone we knew that
we wouldn't see it come to life so that
it was something that we had to talk
about with everyone and like you said a
lot of the investors that we were
pitching don't have vaginas don't have
periods and are frankly afraid of both
so when just go in and you're talking
about both things simultaneously they
don't understand it and so we really
focused on in like the best advice I
feel like I can give is like focus on
building a really incredible business
that speaks for itself and that they
can't avoid and at that point the
product kind of becomes irrelevant
although we definitely had conversations
where they were like like I can't even
tell you guys how many times they've
heard like let me ask my wife or like
can you send a box to my assistant I'll
see what she thinks and those are aren't
people that you want to work with
anyways
so take that as like I'm not interested
and move on and find someone that is and
vanessa was every investor just like
food nurse actually at the time that we
were pitching the the hyper like local
delivery space was pretty crowded so we
really wanted to make it very clear that
you were getting specialty things from
someplace else so what we did is that we
made sure that we had food present you
know to illustrate what we were trying
to what we were trying to do so we would
bring a key lime pie from Key West we
would also do a lot of research of the
about the investor that we were talking
to
where they went to school or where they
were from and we made sure to have
something there that maybe they had a
nostalgic connection to some fad hacker
yeah and it was really cool by the time
they arrived is someone qihai
by the time they arrived at the meeting
and sat down like they saw the food item
and they understood what we were trying
to do so that was we didn't have to like
go through all of this explaining
anymore and the other thing that we used
to do that then we'd follow up with like
another food item delivered to them so a
food man food sells
so when you are trying to figure out
you're getting ready to pitch to
investors for the first time how did you
know what metrics they wanted to see how
did you figure that out we just asked
like before like if Sequoia is you're
like superhot dreamboat don't set that
up as your first meeting go in to like
find an angel that you're also
interested in but like it's not your
number one pick and start practicing
there and ask them like what metrics do
you need to see in a company on my stage
and like what would you be looking for
and they'll tell you I think in our
instance our seed was raised on vision
we were talking about our vision our
experience the team the market size so
it was less about like how what our
metrics were and it's more about like
how are you guys going to win and why
are you guys going to win I think that
by the time we went to raise our Series
A our seed investors were really key in
giving us guidance I'm like what were
the KPIs that were really relevant that
would make you know investors interested
in us so it was through our seed
investors that we learned what metrics
to really put front and center yeah and
I think related to that those KPIs are
going to be critical for your business
anyway so really understanding what
those KPIs are based on the business
type and then tracking those rigorously
as you're growing the company and then
those will give you sort of benchmarks
for where you need to be when you're
going to each rate of round of
fundraising
so how has it changed as you you know
you went to reseed you know an a a B and
now I see how is it changed throughout
that process yeah for me I think
actually the industry has also changed a
lot in that time as well so I think when
we started science exchange 2011 it was
right at that kind of bubble when people
were starting to think about becoming
entrepreneurs but definitely not
available of interest that there is no
that we've seen the huge number of
people in the audience today and so
that's that's amazing to see so many
people wanting to become entrepreneurs
but it also creates a different level of
expectation around where you should be
as a company at each round of financing
so for us when we raised our Series A we
al series day was like three or four
million dollars and that was great that
was like totally normal back then and
now I think the median is close to ten
million so it's a very different type of
expectation around where you should be
what stage of company should be when
you're raising each of these rounds
certainly for us we saw that same focus
on vision on market opportunity and on
team being very important in the early
stages and then much more focus on okay
how are you showing to product market
fit and in NL Serie C that was very
critical that you had very large
enterprise clients that were actually
using this platform extensively and they
had genuinely proved out the business
model in the cost of acquisition and all
of those components that investing this
money would actually immediately go into
creating an ROI for those investors
right so you know as you know you've all
gone through the fundraising process
we've seen the numbers not you know a
huge percentage of women get funded do
you think that at any point in the
process you face specific challenges
because you're women
[Laughter]
sure like absolutely right like me face
unique challenges being women I think I
really struggle with this question
because raising money is hard like hard
stop it is hard for anyone and you don't
want to go into a negotiation or into a
meeting thinking like oh this is going
to be harder for me because I'm a woman
because you're giving that person the
upper hand so it's not to say that it's
not happening but it's like how do you
not think about that so that you can go
into that meeting and you can actually
be the one who is changing that
percentage or that statistic um it's a
little bit hard for me to answer that
question because my co-founder is my he
was my boyfriend now he's my husband so
I just feel like you know for us is as
long as we're you know focusing on
growth and we're showing you know
demonstrating like product market fit
like that we're going to do well I
didn't feel like my gender had anything
to do with where we are today yeah I
think as you get into the later stages
of financing you see perhaps less
because there is much more focus on
metrics so being able to quite a
quantitative ly show that your business
is actually at a point where it deserves
the raise a certain amount of financing
kind of removes an element of bias even
if it's unconscious so my suspicion is
that those earliest rounds the angel
rounds are probably where it's most
difficult and where you might face some
bias and I think we were very fortunate
I also have a co-founder who's a man I
don't know if that helped us or or not
but I certainly think that if you can
push through and get that initial
funding then you start to get traction
in that traction actually you know
Trump's any kind of weird gender issues
yet so that's an interesting you know
I've had a lot of conversations and it
seems like getting those first checks
are the hardest for women and also
that's probably the most vulnerable so
for things that happen it's usually at
that stage before you already have a
network of investors who kind of can
help you through the later stages
of the process so I'm for folks that you
know are maybe raising their first you
know their seed their a what do you have
advice what what is it if someone were
to come to you and say hey can you help
me I'm pitching investors next week what
uh what one or two things would you want
to impart to them I think that a lot of
series a what we did differently is that
we prepared much better for a Series A
than we did for her seed we made sure
that we had our financial model you know
pretty ready to go all of our data was
ready all of our keep kpi's were on
display and we made sure to study up on
all of the key metrics that investors at
a Series A level would be interested in
so by the time we had our meetings we
already had all of the information that
they were going to ask we weren't like
scrambling to like you know we weren't
having different conversations at
different times we were having the same
conversation with everyone showing
everyone the same information and we you
know we we just studied up and prepared
before we had our first series a meeting
so that's a echo something that Eileen
was saying just you have to know those
numbers cold by heart yeah yeah and it's
and it's not just your numbers by the
series a you should also know who you
want to talk to most of the time you're
going to start talking to people that
have already invested in you and of the
seed level or you're going to reach out
to firms that you know can help you you
know get to the next stage so you're
going to have to do a lot more preparing
before doing doing a series day than you
would a seed yeah I agree I mean even at
the seed stage I think that being
prepared is so important like there's so
much research that you can do there's so
many I mean all of you in this room
there are so many people you can talk to
about like what has their experience
then like you know what are the averages
like what should I be looking for go
talk to other investors like I said ask
them what they're looking for
and put that together for the people
that you really really want on your cap
table
and so what of how do you identify those
people that you that you want to talk to
right so how do you figure out who might
be interested in funding a feminine care
product well there aren't many that
funds women care products but look for
look for companies that are similar like
it's not in your category similar to
what you're trying to achieve so like we
have a you know a feminine hygiene
product but we're also an e-commerce
company so like what investors are have
like a really strong presence in
e-commerce
what investors have invested in female
founders stuff like that yeah we were
looking for investors that had expertise
in like consumer brands and marketplaces
so we did a lot of research about like
who could really give us some like
really great advice right where do you
go isn't like anecdotally CrunchBase or
angel yeah you're literally like stock
investor look at doing gingerly what
words they're on yeah yeah I mean if
you're in part of the startup community
you already know what kind of firms you
know focus on different industries so
and how much did fellow founders kind of
you know help you out did some good
folks offer to introduce you to their
investors or they said hey I know
someone like did that ever work reaching
out to you know folks in your community
so one thing that I've that we've always
done is if if we needed an intro to an
investor we would either reach out to a
YC partner or to any of our peers that
maybe had some kind of connection like
through LinkedIn you can figure out
specific who's connected to so yeah we
we would just ask for a personal
interest and how did you divide
responsibility on your team so a lot of
you a lot of you know when you fund
raise it sort of takes so much of your
time and focus so how did you keep the
company running while you were out there
pitching investors what did that break
down
what about remember clay you know that's
definitely very challenging at the
earliest stages and again I think that's
there's something we are minimizing the
time at which you're actually
fundraising and being very focused about
when you're fundraising and when you're
not fundraising is very important
because you have to have you know really
strong metrics going into the fundraise
and then if it's just you know three
co-founders and you know two of your
fundraising you're going to have a dip
in your metrics because you're doing
nothing else except summarizing and so
that's very challenging I think once you
get beyond that initial phase of only
having a few people in the company
hopefully you're at a point where the
company should continue to operate more
or less seamlessly without you being in
the office every day and that's a lot
easier so definitely I seriously was so
much easier from that from that regard
but I think would be great to hear you
know how you guys handled that so for
our seed round we everything slowed down
right our entire team was focused on and
somehow helping raise around but by the
time we did the series a our CEO Joe he
did he basically did the round as I
focused on operations I made sure that
we were still running and then we were
so growing that we were sticking to to
our our goals and our metrics month to
month so we could you know keep making
money the vast majority of like running
the company was up to you for a while
yes for the along did it take um we did
it pretty quickly the reason we did it
pretty quickly is because we had gotten
profitable before we went out for a
series a which I forgot to mention like
that also helps speed up the process if
you've already worked out your unit
economics and you you become profitable
then you know you have a little bit more
rip leverage to have you know I feel
like a faster fundraise process so
probably I would say just a couple
months yeah but I was basically involved
in the day-to-day for our product in our
marketing
and BD as he was focusing on talking to
investors Erica
yeah similar for us we have three
co-founders our CEO Lauren really
focused on fundraising and we always say
I kind of stayed home and like made sure
that the kids were still growing
um which like meant keeping the company
running and keeping the traction that we
were showing investors making sure that
it was continuing you could go back in
time and give yourself a piece of advice
to when you were first starting a
company you know first starting the
company what would you tell yourself
doesn't have to be about fundraising
just generally um I think a lesson that
I've learned being a founder is when you
start your company you're pretty
obsessed and you put your everything and
your all into your work into your
product into what you're trying to build
and you kind of lose yourself you feel
that if you work 24/7 you're going to be
better and you're going to like help
your company take off but what you don't
realize is that you can burn out if
you're just working 24/7 but if you
leave work and go home and continue to
work you're not going to make better
decisions for your company it's actually
going to slow you down so it took me a
couple of years to figure out how to
have a good life and work balance I
think I had like no idea how hard being
a founder was going to be enough about
the Vice but more so like how like I
wish I could have I wish I would have
met more founders in the beginning to
have talked to about about it and like
learn from them and just like be able to
[ __ ] about like everything that you
have to go through because it's hard
it's really hard I hope you all use each
other but I do yeah I know yeah I
definitely think that learning process
of trying to get advice earlier trying
to not be afraid to sort of talk about
the challenges you're facing and and you
know everyone is always like crushing it
and doing so well on the outside
you know at times these you're like well
maybe I'm not doing well enough and like
you don't know who you can really talk
to about and I think the reality is
everybody feels like that and that if
you were just really honest about that
people will say oh yeah you know what I
had exact same thing and I'm so worried
about it as well and you can realize
that every single company is so messed
up and I have and I remember Jessica
talking about this at one of the female
founders conferences and I was like it's
really true I mean you always think that
everything that you're doing is so much
worse than everybody else
but the reality is everybody is just
trying their best and creating these
amazing companies in the process but
it's not perfect it's not perfect for
anybody along the way cool thank you
guys so much for taking the time thank
you
[Applause]
you